welcome and most importantly
congratulations congratulations everyone
who's nominated tonight thank you for
letting me be a part of this I'm excited
I've never been to the Oscars before
this is my first time here and the way
you people go through a host is probably
my last time here so I'm going to enjoy
this while I'm here this broadcast is
being watched live by millions of
Americans and around the world in more
than 225 countries that now hate us and
I think that is an amazing thing as you
know I don't have to tell anybody this
country is divided right now I've been
getting a lot of advice people been
telling me it's time to bring everyone
together you need to say something to
unite us and let's just get something
straight off it's up I'm not I can't do
that that's not there's only one brave
heart in this room and he's not going to
unite us either okay
no you look great I think the
Scientology is working I really do
I'm not the man to unite this country
but it can be done we you know if every
person watching this show I don't wanna
get too serious but there are millions
and millions of people watching right
now and if every one of you took a
minute to reach out to one person you
disagree with someone you like and have
a positive considerate conversation
others liberals or conservatives as
Americans because we would all do that
we can make America great again we
really could starts with us and tonight
in the spirit of healing and bringing
people together
I would like to bury the hatchet with
someone I've had issues with
I was Matt Damon now Matt I've known
Matt for a long time now you know what I
know Matt so long when I first met Matt
I was the fat one okay crew and we've
had problems he's a selfish person those
of you worked with him know them but
Matt did something very unselfish and I
want to commend him for it I for real
Matt as you probably know could have
started Manchester by the sea he was the
producer its nominated for six Oscars
including lead actor and he could have
taken that lead actor part for himself
but he didn't he gave that role to Casey
Affleck his childhood friend he handed
would turn out to be an Oscar caliber
roll over to his friend and made a
Chinese ponytail movie instead
and
[Applause]
and that movie the Great Wall went on to
lose eighty million dollars movemove
amass see it's so easy to reach out in
the heel we and I want to say I remain
it is not a popular thing to say but I
want to say thank you to President Trump
I mean remember last year when it seemed
like the Oscars were racist thanks what
inner it has been an amazing year for
movies black people save NASA and white
people save jazz that's where we fall
progress a little movie musical names
la-la-land ties the all-time Oscar
record record it was directed by Damien
Chazelle 14 nominations 14 nominations
one for every year Damien has been alive
tonight is very important for Damien if
he wins we'll be able to go to any
college he want so we wish you the best
the movie business is changing the first
time ever Amazon is represented at the
Academy Awards Amazon is the first
streaming service nominated for Best
Picture Jeff Bezos is the founder and
CEO and I want to say congratulations to
Jeff you know I also want you know
jeopardy if you win tonight you could
expect your Oscar to arrive in two to
five business days possibly stolen by a
GrubHub delivery man Amazon produced
Manchester by the sea that was a fun
movie wasn't it you know if you search
for a Manchester buddy see on Amazon it
says customers who bought this item also
purchased zola I don't know what's going
on but there are a lot of sad movies
this year of all the nominees the only
happy ending of 'allah nominees was the
one in the middle of moonlight
you didn't watch it did you oh we loved
it so much the incredible Denzel
Washington is nominated for fences a
movie he also directed I don't know
you've probably heard the story but of
how it came together apparently Denzel
had always wanted to work with Denzel
and just so happened that their
schedules worked out and the rest is
Oscar history congratulations to you my
friend
we have friends and colleagues visiting
from all around the world tonight the
great actress from France Isabel who
pair is here with us Isabel as you know
is nominated for a performance in the
movie L and on behalf of everyone here I
would like to say we didn't see el but
we absolutely loved it you were amazing
in that film and I'm glad Homeland
Security let you in tonight I really am
we are very welcoming to outsiders here
in Hollywood we don't discriminate
against people because based on what
countries they they come from we we
discriminate against them based on their
age and weight Andrew Garfield lost 40
pounds where is Andrew and you can
barely even see him he got so thin there
he is
he lost 40 pounds for his role in the
movie silence it was an astonishing
physical transformation that hasn't been
attempted since every actress in every
role ever
Viggo Mortensen who's terrific is
nominated for Best Actor for his
performance in the movie captain
fantastic and it is so well deserved
too often the Academy only recognizes
movies that people have seen and I just
think it's wonderful we are here tonight
to honor great actors but also here to
honor the actors who seem great but
actually really aren't and of all the
great actors here in Hollywood one in
particular has stood the test of time
for her many uninspiring and overrated
performances
I mean
may I say from from her mediocre early
work in The Deer Hunter and Out of
Africa humor underwhelming performances
in Kramer vs Kramer and Sophie's Choice
Meryl Streep has phoned it in for more
than 50 films over the course of her
lackluster career this is Meryl xx Oscar
nomination even more made even more
amazing considering the fact that she
wasn't even in a movie this year we just
wrote her name down out of habit Meryl
stand up if you would everybody please
join me in giving Meryl Streep a totally
undeserved round of applause
he highly overrated Meryl Streep
everyone we're gonna have fun tonight I
hope we're going to have fun tonight
nice dress by the way is that an Ivanka
this is exciting I think it's important
that we all know we've all seen it all
but it's important that we take a second
to appreciate what is happening here
we're at the Academy Award you're
nominated you got to come your families
are nominated your friends some of you
will get to come up here on this stage
tonight and give a speech that the
President of the United States will
tweet about in in all caps during his 5
a.m. bowel movement tomorrow and I think
that's pretty darn excellent if you ask
me